somebody's upset that they weren't
selected here and Paulie didn't want to
tell me who it is this is a heavyweight
in the sports industry pulling the
legendary broadcaster Jim Brock Meyer oh
no Jimmy sorry Patrick what the hell is
going on over there uh what I'm having
flashbacks to grade school I'm like
standing around and I'm going to be
picked last they're gonna fire a
dodgeball of my head you never know
what's going to happen you're a little
older
Jim although I love the appearance last
night during the Mets broadcast it was
it was uh it was to the point it was
insightful it was funny just everything
that you are but you're you're sort of a
Brent Musburger now you you're in the
twilight of your career whoa whoa whoa
whoa why'd you now you just got nasty
why would you bring up my nemesis why
would you bring at it let's face it the
most hated man in America I mean what is
this what's going on here what's
happening to you then I why is so filled
with hate I don't mean to be Jim but I I
apologize that we've overlooked you I
didn't know that you and Musburger did
not get alone oh I think you do that
very well I see discredited button.this
and I went much bigger is retired he's
now what is he runs a sports book in Las
Vegas now but nathan is [ __ ] stare
at a big board of a young alive dentist
yeah that's what he does
I'm just restarting like I'm just
getting back in the game well come on
mother here well you know what we'll
factor you in Jim we have one more round
here and and by the way yes you know
what did you say about Keith Hernandez
last night during the Mets broadcast I
begged I made a public appeal that Keith
Hernandez never shaved his mustache
again but I would rather see his exposed
junk than his exposed upper liver
not many baseball announcers describe
the action like that but that's what
makes you Jim Brock Meyer well there's
lots of stuff I didn't get to like about
injury
yeah what what didn't you get a little
regret well as rouble Cabrera the Mets
have listed him as dated
with a bruised stump you see I speak met
those so that actually means that the
man has three days to live
[Laughter]
now our thoughts and prayers go out to
his family but they should have known
what to expect as soon as he put out a
met uniform the Matt Harvey story is
pretty topical - there Jim
yes I commented on that I said that he
was suspended for three games for not
showing up to the ballpark which means
that you literally literally that
Patrick cannot pay people to watch a
message Jim good luck in round three of
the sports media draft and we do love
the the Jim Brock Meyer story on IFC at
10 p.m. Wednesday night tune in make up
for not Twitter picking me in you and
your mean boy League start up your
latest sportscaster league thank you Jim
thank you that's that's Jim Brock Meyer
legendary Jim Brock mom didn't know he
listens I'm listening to him last night
Gilda Mets game I it feels like if you
just plugged him in and had him do the
Padre games like it would be must listen
if you put Jim Brock Meyer in there and
let him do a season of games with you
know a team that's not you know not a
good team at all he's very funny though
he was funny last night on the Mets
broadcast the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience